enjoy his work on the ringer and I would
love to get his thoughts on all of this
Kevin Clark joining me here from the
ringer right here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Kevin I'm doing good I'm
ready for some football whatever you
want to call this from ready for a
Friday night
well I mean it's it's a draft you know
it's not gonna look the same at all we
know that it's not gonna look anything
like what we what we think of a draft I
mean Roger Goodell just tweeted out a
video of him walking around his house
showing you where the cards are gonna be
and where this person's gonna be and
where that person's gonna be you know
but we're gonna get a draft and it's
gonna be significant and when we do get
football back one day it's gonna have a
huge ripple effect do you think the
Dolphins are making that Godfather offer
to the Bengals what do you think I think
they're gonna try you know I spent some
time in Miami in December and I talked
to Chris Brewer about this and I said
what's the plan and they said listen
when you force it that's when mistakes
are made and I think they're talking
about evaluation I think they're talking
about you know reaching to a third
quarterback in the draft or something
like that but I think that if they're
convinced that buro is the guy they're
gonna try to make that offer because
that borough is not forcing it I mean
maybe throwing a bunch of first-round
picks it's forcing it from a value
standpoint but from an evaluation
standpoint it's not geez the guy do
everything you can to godfather offer
the bangles and you're doing it I don't
think the Bengals are gonna do it I
think that they've they've made up their
mind it's a little late in the process
obviously but I think that no one's
something I remember Mike Shanahan
saying this no one has ever said that
someone's overpaid for a franchise
quarterback it's never happened if the
franchise guy go get them fact that's a
fact Kevin I mean that's a fact so you
know Dolphins fans that may have just
heard the scenario playing out that the
Bengals would trade out of one if they
all they have to do is fall to three and
then have a five right after they picked
the two of the first five picks in this
year's draft and then figure out
quarterback from there on out they might
be willing to do that and then the
Dolphins have to get within hailing
distance for the lines to be comfortable
to hop hop out of three and not lose so
much if in the Dolphins used draft
Capitol and tomorrow night's second
round and then only choose once in the
top and the first round because
of all of this and they get borrow
that's the end of that if they if they
win for four years with Joe borough you
know exactly exactly and no one's gonna
say they paid too much if Joe borough
turned out to be the Joe bro we think
you can't I think there's a lot of
there's so many outstanding issues there
I think it's a tough road there's a
tough path to getting that and not
giving up the fish stick to get the
third pick and all that but listen they
have more draft capital really than any
team in the last couple of decades they
took the biggest dead calf charge in
history last year they are rebuilding
very very quickly and they understand
how to do it and they understand that
getting Joe borough is the end of the
rebuild it ends tonight if they can do
that and they understand that that's why
that's wrong Kevin Clarke here on the
Rich Eisen show what else you hearing
what else you think might actually
happen tonight sir what you got for me
I'm really intrigued to see what the
trade process looks like you know I
talked to a couple people think there's
gonna be quote unquote package trades
which are trades that are agreed upon
before the draft
okay this prospect is there than this
because they just don't want the chaos
of calling a team with with four minutes
left on the clock and seeing what they
can work out I think that generally the
quarterback thing I'm a docent every
every draft is about quarterbacks in
some ways whether that's getting a
quarterback or taking advantage of the
team that doesn't have a quarterback
which might be happening with Miami
right now and the way that to uh way to
is approached by chance this is the
strangest offseason history of football
it's the strangest draft in history of
football and to in that regard is one of
the most unique prospects because this
is a guy who you know teams cannot
independently check out his hip they
cannot independently work him out I
think that with that in mind I think the
case made the Tewa is the most
intriguing prospect in the last couple
of dress just because of the fact these
he's an incredible channel who can't get
worked out by teams and we just don't
know how the season is gonna play out to
where I I don't know teams overthinking
or under think it was to of going into
tonight it's over thing come on I mean
this guy's special I honestly honestly
sometimes
the evaluation does not appear on an MRI
sometimes the evaluation does not appear
in an x-ray machine and I know that that
is a huge part of it and I know that
that's why the combine was created all
right but sometimes the best evaluation
is with two eyes that's it your own two
eyes and I think this kid is absurdly
special and man the ceiling is so high
with him I think it's over think
personally yeah I agree with you and I
think that there's you know I felt some
scouting reports where teams were saying
oh well he's an RPO guy or we can't do
pro-style stuff
well then become an RPO team I mean one
of the lessons of the last five years of
football is if you take a guy and
builder on what he can do well you will
win and I think that's gonna take some
creativity for offensive coordinator
like this is the lesson of Lamar Jackson
I went to Baltimore in January and asked
a couple of guys around that locker room
I said hey look you know there's not
gonna be a next Lamar Jackson but what
coming on from Lamar and Robert Griffin
ever saying this he said the lesson is
to take what a guy can do well anything
and you can't drive I need to run any
offense as long as you believe in it I
got and with to you maybe he can't do
everything but he can run an RPO maybe
better than anybody in the history of
the college game so just do that over
over again I think the HIPAA be fine I
think there's a lot of questions about
the autism programs and training camp
and how this all plays that I think
they're getting a franchise guys to get
to and I think that I'm with you do not
overthink this he's the guy Kevin Clark
the ringer NFL writer and and I've
always enjoyed following you on Twitter
right here on the Rich Eisen show so how
many quarterbacks do you think Oh
tonight what do you think I think it's
four I think it's four and I think
that's only because I think there's a
lot of good teams you know I think
probably 27 or 28 teams have plans at
quarterback which is pretty pretty high
considering how desperate a lot of
innocent Libre Mike Glennon got 45
million dollars couple years ago right
and I think that once Jordan loved once
Herbert comes off the board obviously
probably in the top ten
jordan loves going to
dangling there and I think a team we're
not thinking about who has a plan at
quarterback who has a starter might say
hey let's just let's just save for the
future here you know I've seen them mock
to Green Bay a handful of times toxic
really smart people a team like that who
was set at quarterback who might want to
stash it away for a rainy day and have a
young quarterback inside the development
process I think that that's how that
plays out I would guess for and then
that would be love going where and when
what do you think I'm gonna agree with
some of the smart people and say I would
not be surprised if if Green Bay doesn't
start planning
close to 40 I mean that means you're
gonna that means you're going to Aaron
Rodgers Jordan love it's basically I
understand what the seven but I mean and
I understand that football is so crazy
that yes that Aaron Rodgers end of his
Packers career he could be in the role
of Favre and then somebody is in the
role of Aaron Rodgers but that makes no
sense to me for a team that has not this
is what one fact Chris that I know if
you saw in the mock draft last night
with Daniel Jeremiah the last time the
Packers chose an offensive player in the
first round told Aaron Rodgers here
here's a some help on offense for the
first rounder was the year after they
won the Super Bowl of him and they chose
an offensive lineman whose name escapes
me now from Mississippi State who played
for years Malik and they've gone defense
first round every year since then so you
tell me they will finally add an
offensive player through the first round
but it's the guy to replace an Rogers I
mean the Packers are really into
athleticism and drafting and drafting
really good athletes I think that that's
partly the reasons they've always gone
they've gone with a lot of quarterbacks
a lot of defensive linemen that sort of
thing they like to draft those kind of
athletes in a first round that was true
Ted Thompson it's not true of Brian good
and kunst and I think that I just think
that there's a possibility we see a
curveball like that
am i 100% you know Daniel Jeremiah was
the first person it's worth rotas out
there that that love could be a
possibility for a team like the Packers
I just think that when you're a smart
organization I think the Packers are you
understand the value of having a
quarterback plant and a quarterback pipe
by the penguin Rodgers and a lot of
money a lot of money historically high
money I think he made 166 million
dollars in cash in one year two years
ago and they're committed to him but I
think that you know I remember somebody
in jeopardy Larry said to me once where
they don't in the Eagles of stability
they don't even call it the backup
quarterback they call it the second
quarterback because he's always gonna
play and that's something that you know
Nick Foles you have a review event but I
feel like having a plan for a smart team
it's always a good thing I hear you and
I guess we might find out what the
Saints ultimate evaluation of Taysom
Hill is if if they pass on Jordan love
tonight and he's still sitting out there
in the 20s you know and and Jordans on
my show he's the next guest on this show
Kevin you ask interesting questions for
a living what would you want to know
from Jordan love Wow
I mean I I want to know and completely I
whether or not you answer this is a
separate thing but I I'm really
intrigued to see what he thinks about
this offseason and whether or not what
the realistic goals are considering
there's gonna be no rookie minicamp
considering there's gonna probably be no
veteran minicamp and there might not be
a training camp that were used to that
starts on you know he's reporting July
24th all that and I think that that's
going to change a lot for rookies and
remember this happened in 2011 with the
lockout where there's no offseason and
everyone said well the rookie class is
screwed
well then Cam Newton comes out and has a
historically good year JJ Watt AJ Green
Julio Jones all those guys came in that
year everything was fine but for a guy
who needs a little more development like
Jordan Love who would come into a system
and try to learn it and try to get on
the same page does this put him a little
bit behind the eight ball because I
can't help but think it does and I think
that's also part of the reason we might
see a team with a quarterback plan go
the guy like to earn love because it's
going to take an extra year maybe to
work them into the system with webOS
elses go all right
the Kevin Clark of the ringer here on
the Rich Eisen show a few more minutes
left with him and
helping me do my job make it easier for
me later on in the show I mean that'll
be an interesting question to ask him
for sure and then there's the
comparisons to mahomes that everybody
keeps throwing out there I'm going to
talk about unfair I don't know what's
more unfair Boro is the next Brady or
love is the next mahomes I don't know
what's more unfair but I've heard both
of those evaluations you know yeah
Holmes was such a unique prospect and
scouts missed on him for so many
different reasons one of them was even
so competitive that he was throwing you
know he fell you to score 70 points
every game which he kind of did a Texas
Tech and so he was making some may be
more competitive passes and he should
have maybe some more because he both he
should have but I think that because he
was Holmes was kind of a flawed prospect
in some ways and because of that more
people are going to compare him get
compared to mahomes and probably should
I mean almost reminds me a little bit of
Brett Favre when he was in his prime
rich where because he was he was not
perfect on every throw everybody coming
out of college got compared to threat
bar but was actually kind of funny and I
think that probably happens a little bit
because of the way he was in the
prospect okay Kevin Clarke here on the
Rich Eisen show what else do you think
we're talking about tomorrow
have we hit everything I mean the
receivers are fascinating where they all
go I mean Daniel Jeremiah and his mock
draft had them all going in a row a run
from 12 to 15 tonight that every single
team from the Raiders Niners Bucks to
the Broncos take the top receivers where
do you think they go it's gonna be run
on tackles in the top ten and then the
receivers I'm with you that run in the
mid team starts this is the deepest
receiver class in really in history and
there's a million reasons for that you
know everyone talks to the seven on
sevens and how the receivers are just
better athletes and they were 10 15
years ago but I think that there's
they're smart teams who understand that
you can get value in the second or third
round but I think the Alabama guys will
go in the mid-teens I think there's so
much game-changing talent throughout the
draft with with receivers I think once
one goes the others will go same with
tackles but that'll be in a top 10 it's
a really deep draft in a couple
positions and I'm really intrigued to
see how that plays out I know it's so
it's it's exciting man it's exciting and
I know there was
large pushback in the talent evaluation
community when it was first thrown out
there like hey this is gonna happen so
everybody get ready this is gonna happen
and and and everybody has gotten ready
your ear to the ground have you heard
people still grumbling about this thing
I it seems that there is some grumbling
because it took about all of ten seconds
for someone to text shefter what what
what a holy mess the Monday run-through
was so I'm wondering what you hear Kevin
I think they're starting to get a handle
on this and out there got him they're
kind of excited in the same way they are
always excited I thought too Brandon
being last week the bill GM and he was
you know he was talking about how
normally you get the the prospects in
the building and you did interact with
them and he was worried you weren't
going to be able to get the same read on
a guy is a guy he's gonna stare at his
phone if you're gonna be unreliable and
you miss that part of it and and being
told me well actually the guys who would
have missed their flight last year
they're just not showing up for their
Zune calls or they're not responding to
texts from from GM's who want to set up
an appointment or whatever and so you're
not really missing a whole lot from the
email process I think a GM - you know
what as much information is possible
always uncomfortable with the idea that
they were gonna miss some pieces I their
understanding how to get that
information now in a different way I
think the people who were against it and
who at the beginning of this process are
still against it but not a hundred
percent against I mean most people like
Brandon being where they've learned to
understand the new reality of it and
they're okay with this whole thing and
and they understand this can be a normal
draft picks wise if not you know
work-wife so are you saying that missing
a zoom call or not responding to texts
from a general manager in the NFL being
sent to a prospect immediately or if at
all that's the new red flag in the
evaluation so what you're saying yeah
it's part of it it's part of it and it's
funny because I you know Rob Gronkowski
visited the Patriots you know nine years
ago and fell asleep front his meeting as
pre-draft meeting famously Bilbao
checkers told that story on the iPhone
Network yeah and so I think that
it is a red flag to have a bad visit and
even though it's not you know obviously
not fatal and I think that with in lieu
of flights and talking to the driver you
know tell the driver is always a big
thing a piece of these things you're not
going to get that so the closest thing
you're going to get to that miss in this
process is did they get on the zoom call
at the time they were going to being
told me that there were there were guys
who had three zoom cult set up for three
different people in the organization it
didn't show up for any of them so that's
that's that is the new red flag and it's
your reality it's like a job interview
and but you can't do it remote so you're
doing it remotely and you're just like
have you heard Kevin have you heard
maybe that there's a red flag because a
prospect accidentally shared their
screen and showed what was on their
screen pre-draft process I'm sure one
guy accidentally shared it screen by
John Schneider said this on the
commentary today
one guy was just in bed the whole time
just hanging out watching TV and just
talking to talking to the Seahawks so
this is a these guys are getting a new
perspective on some of these prospects
and again you can you can learn a lot
about it so that's amazing more
information on that one which Snyder's
at somebody so somebody's zooming in and
they're just like I'm not getting out of
bed for you yesterday I did so I guess
it's just guys were saying you know what
hey it's working home oh you know I'm a
shut pants no need to move by the way
and that's the team the mantra always
compete
that's the rule that's might be out of
all third about the Belichick do your
job how many teams would that's a bad
team to choose to just not get out of
bed for your for your zoom is say say to
Pete Carroll yeah I know I know you'd
look at absolutely everything that I do
is my desire or whether you want to
compete and then because we'll give you
a chance if you do buy into always
compete just look at our quarterback
right look at Shaq Griffin
and the kid doesn't get out of bed or
out of his sweat pants bad choice that's
a bad choice yeah yeah he mentioned the
sander did mention the press comment
that there were people who wore ties to
their pre-draft now they recall hey I'll
share with you Kevin last night I did an
entire show on NFL Network from the from
my desk left position in my office
suit and tie suited but not booted I was
wearing shorts the entire time no one
has to know I mean I just shared that
but no one knows waist up I'm a pro
waist down not so much you know that's
just the way to do it well we're all
doing a little III when I go on camera I
worked high a couple weeks ago yes and
there were a lot of people who were very
mad at me about this they were saying
hey man this is not it's not the time
for ties Kevin Clark here on the Rich
Eisen show Kevin it's a time for
designer jacket oh that's fantastic I
love it I mean that is leather
that's like leather that's a snap at the
top that is very impressive before I let
you go what are we what are you
expecting in episodes 3 and 4 of the
last dance on Sunday what expect oh my
gosh I'm Orlando so III purely through
the Orlando Magic Prizm I'm hoping that
he doesn't embarrass them anymore
even though he didn't during his visit
during his career I'm just expecting
more in say I'm in the Rodman episode
it's going to happen I guess this is the
first episode I mean this is one of the
best things that I've ever consumed from
it sports it's not a game so I'm just
expecting Jordan making fun of more
people owning more people and some more
shots of Jerry crowd well I mean you
know I loved your tweet saying that
somewhere there's a member of the 8485
pools telling them telling their loved
ones in the living room they were not
part of the cocaine circus that was
hilarious
could you imagine a Warren sharp smart
he said he said they're also in
quarantine so they can't even leave the
house that's if your wife
your child is like what hey whatever
1984 dad me well now you can't you can't
say well I gotta go to the store real
quick you can't even buy some time that
is true it's just sitting hey everybody
here let's all sit back and watch the
greatest player that dad ever ever
played with you know
dad dad or uncle played with Michael
let's just sit down and see what they
say about the first year or they knew it
was coming and they're like yeah we just
for some reason we can't get ESPN there
must be some sort of you know there must
be some sort of Rights fee battle that's
going around the power's out oh man good
chat Kevin thanks for the time we uh we
will chat with you next week and maybe
get your thoughts on on what we what we
see tonight and the rest of the weekend
thanks for the time that's it that's
Kevin Clark right here on the Rich Eisen
show from the ringer from Simmons ringer
great perspective right there man hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here